about a gender nah example men tend to
be better in leadership I mean
stereotypes are there for a reason and
they come from somewhere you know but
overall we are generalizing and I feel
like there's a lot of like we've been
bashing right now with in the workplace
but if we look at it as well you know
in history the women went to work what
sort of from the 50s and 60s and whereas
we first had you know the women being
the homeowner
Homemaker that's the word I'm looking
for work on like the farm too yeah sorry
I'm thinking you awesome actually I was
thinking about the us too that's where I
read the statistics from but basically
when the women went into the workforce
sort of the family side of things
struggled that was also when divorce
rates went up by I think like 80 or
something crazy like that but it was
also after the development of birth
control yes it all came around the same
same time yeah but I mean um they're
like bring me back to the streets
I think we're gonna be that this
particular like men are better than
leaders oh where is this world going I
can't say nothing God just think out
loud at this point is bloody hell no
wait so you're saying we should be able
to say that
it's just European yes exactly anybody
hasn't got any references into anything
graphic or inappropriate
yeah because I just don't know we keep
saying we keep saying there are
exceptions and I'm like I know there are
exceptions but like we can make General
statements about to be fair though I do
think it depends on the topic with
generalization like the topics that we
had before that were very like it could
be very yeah touch like touchy in
subjects it generalizing can be too much
like when you were both going and
talking about like the specifics of the
numbers you were using it can be
dependent on the topic really say
generalization we all do it with
everything but yeah with certain like
subjects you have to be a bit more
particular I think I think nowadays
um
with the rise
and evolution of feminism
um more women
um who here
um certain generalizations that don't
necessarily paint
um women in a good light or take umbrage
to those generalizations and then those
will be that they will be the ones to
say something you know get triggered and
want to kind of dispute it or even if
even if it's a factual thing
um though they will still say I don't
agree you can still fudge the numbers
though so statistically there are more
men in the workforce therefore the
statistics will lean better into their
their favor so in order to say that men
are better leaders numerically they are
better leaders
no because they asked women that the
study I was saying was um they they
picked female lead Industries and
they're like with the female-led
industry I can I can I can read it you
have to be very careful pearly things
what about statistics because
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
watch it guys guys what should guys
Who's laughing in the mic it's me I'm
sorry I'm sorry I apologize what should
we go off our feelings so if we don't go
off of stats what are we going to go off
of but I can like who wrote These
statistics who funded these statistics
thank you the let's see
[Music]
a new study UCLA okay it's a university
yeah I know the I know the University
thank you yeah it says I've taught at
UCLA
[Music]
um
a much smaller survey by UCLA Law Firm
staff UCLA yeah them it's a college
American so it's not UCL no they they
took stats from the UK to I think no no
this is American oh it's American yeah I
think interesting I think what she's
trying to say thank you um is just how
many people
would actually fill out stuff to do with
this and then those demographical people
I don't care for what I'm actually
saying just trying to reference what
she's saying so those people that would
fill out a survey versus people that
wouldn't feel like surfing
this is just it's just I just feel like
sometimes we jump through hoops whenever
women like I just feel like sometimes I
feel like we we jump through hoops
whenever women look bad like to to
somehow change the narrative for us not
to look bad but we can say women run the
world and nobody nobody even pushes back
on that
so it's like you have to understand we
can always so
with Statistics okay so men line numbers
don't men like women like numbers don't
lie but numbers can be manipulated
depending on who's looking at them and
what they wanted to say so we can say
that right but if we look generally how
the world since the beginning of time
has done censuses then we we we take the
majority or we take it we take a slice
of it and then we we generalize right if
we don't do that we will never ever able
to come to some type of like general you
know decision on something so we have to
do that it might not be perfect
Sometimes some people might get roped
into it some people might get left out
but this is the best that we have and
this is what and this is what the world
has been using since the beginning of
time from when from when Pontius Pilate
had to go do sentences and go literally
from then them times there from when the
Passover was happening and they wanted
to know how many people were inside each
from them times they'd be taking numbers
down yeah so unless one of you guys can
give me I was gonna say I can go and
give me one day because because you're
speaking about before the dawn of time
before the dawn of time it was a man's
man's world that's the saying that a lot
of people like to bring up here from
back in the day like it's a man's world
everything's very man-made because men
built the world yeah but for me it's
like condition of the Mind see it from
my perspective I added psychology so I
believe that everything is like some
form of like introductory it's like
planting a seed it's going to grow if
I'm always surrounded by male
counterparts in power if I'm always
being told that a male is the one that's
meant to hold me down you know protect
me like Amel is meant to be you know my
version of God essentially because he's
meant to be my everything at this point
this is the society that they built up
on we've created the women couldn't do
it yeah there's no such thing that we
couldn't we wasn't given a child no we
were that we could have done it just
like the men did it but like no but wait
wait but no but no Society wait wait
wait wait stop do not interrupt me no no
society that has stood the test of time
was run by women women had just as much
opportunity as men
and men and men still run the world I
mean they run our whole infrastructure
if if men disappeared tomorrow like the
lights would go out the plumbing would
stop women disappeared they would be
fine but it's possible to to an extent
but the point that I'm trying to makers
that imagine if you're only being
surrounded by a male energy you're not
going to know any difference to them
yeah but I want to know I want to know
I've had it statistics I'm giving more
prominent Mal do you get it because
everyone's been surrounded by my mouth
if he was forced to be in a female you
know I am we live okay so management
wise we're talking about management no
but I'm talking about consent I'm
talking about census and getting a
demographic of people I want to know how
the fact that men like men are there
like what you say make sixty thousand
women all the senses say that actually
working for a woman creates me more
problems I want to know what what has
men done to make women say actually if I
work for a woman I don't actually like
it as much sixty thousand sixty thousand
men are attracted to women so of course
women are going to have a better working
experience working for men
women are attracted to men
yeah it's equal it's equal but the only
difference is that women women don't
like working for women they like working
for men men say I don't care you know I
feel like men have a certain approach
like we're saying women and men are very
different in the workplace and I feel
like their approaches are different so
maybe males tend to like interactive
women in a more like you know they
understand the nature of women hiring
people has actually like kind of put me
like understand like why there's more
uh men and Leadership positions and
positions of power because I found like
the the best paid jobs and the high like
jobs like women don't want to do because
it's they're stressful so like
so I'll give you an example so my
recruiting my recruiter like that's
probably one of the highest paid jobs I
have that's a really hard job to get
that many people in like what any 20 to
50 girls four days a week that's really
hard and stressful because if you don't
get me guests like the whole show fails
so it's it's paid well but it's also
high stress but I I had um my roommate
just I said you would make way more
money you can do this job she did it for
a week she said you can't pay me to do
this this sucks and when I when I I
brought the job to my team no one on my
team wanted to do it and it's like they
could make double what they're making at
their jobs that they do but it's hard
oh you showed us I've been I agree but
that may be a little bit of law of
averages yeah what do you mean uh law of
average of like obviously it would have
been a waste of time and money that's
why you wouldn't go on the route of law
on average but if you tried more and
more girls you would have stumbled
across one that could handle it you did
it oh I'm not saying that like no women
can do it no that's not what I'm saying
that I'm like I I would I would kill I
used to do recruiting I would kill oh my
God I would I would kill the recruiting
but like I just think in general women
don't want to do those jobs like like
across the board like women don't want
the super high stress jobs
and even even like oil rigs right like
that that's a six-figure job you can do
right away how many of y'all want to go
work on an oil rig
yeah yeah you couldn't pay me to they
could pay me 300K a year you would not
catch me on an oil rate that goes back
to like it's a man's world a lot of
things were started from men doing a lot
of yeah I'm saying nope
I think imagine I think women just don't
want to do hard jobs I feel like we just
don't want to do something that doesn't
serve us well I feel that for myself I
don't mind doing a job that can be a bit
you know intense but it needs to serve
me well I feel like some women don't
feel like they've been served well so
100 so you could work you could work on
the nights on the trains engineering or
train you know guys on the orange and
that yeah yeah you can there's not
nothing stopping you from doing that job
nothing for me you can make 100K doing
that job yeah it doesn't how can 100K
not serve you well not to say that 100K
is not saving me well but do I want to
be bending and straining my back long
term for how many years that's going to
give me a long term you know Health
right right
okay but if we don't do it okay wait so
let me do that no no no no no no but if
we don't do that job if we don't do that
job you cannot catch a train that
no no no no no no no no because this
what you're doing is another guy that
will but you
you so so but you could but you won't do
something else no but this is this is
this
is the point when I said like met like
women don't want to build the world
because like even no no no no
sorry
this is what I'm saying like in society
like you were saying it's cultural right
and like like because women didn't see
like women in positions of power it's
all influence but even today when we
have every opportunity women still don't
want to do it they don't want to do the
hardest jobs which put your body on the
line of course like I said yeah that's
that was one of the things
I used to interview there was there was
a point there is a point where I
interviewed um top Executives
um I just decided I wanted more rich
friends and it's kind of funny you can
call them up yeah I just thought it was
like my friend group two broke
and so what I did was I like to network
um this is when I was 22 I just called
them up and said I'm 22. I want to learn
and like I talked to like top Executives
at billion dollar companies and you get
to see the toll like because they've
been working 80 you know on their face
seriously they look so tired they look
so burned out because they've been
working 80 hours a week for 30 40 years
who wants to do that you couldn't pay me
to work that much
like I think it's also we need to
acknowledge that it's sort of like a
generational trauma thing because if you
saw your dad working 80 hours and you're
you know that your granddad did that and
then that's the generation that you came
from no trauma my dad loves it he still
works
maybe not not generational trauma just a
generational pattern shall we say but
when you see you know because we lead by
example as parents so we sort of are
conditioned whether it's negatively or
positively to sort of go into the same
sort of roles as our parents it's when
we break those patterns that go off and
do different things that that's like a
little bit strange no no it's just I
make observations and I just I like
again my dad has friends that are in
similar fields in him like do as well as
he does and I'm just saying women I
promise women because the women don't
see it exactly I agree with you on that
yeah because again they've seen their
generations of patterns with maybe
um you know the the home what was the
word Homemakers
um you know they've seen the Homemakers
or they've seen you know their their the
women in their family in certain roles
and then because they've been you know
again like learning from older these
people we've been we've had been able to
work since the 70s
actually it they say that it takes like
two decades for like a changeably
implemented in society like fully so I
do still think we are changing the
gender they started entering the
workforce at World War II sorry go ahead
go ahead no no I'm
I just think that it's going to take
more time if women want these big jobs
and they probably won't want the more
physical ones that they're not possible
you know able to do but I think it will
just take longer for women to have those
higher roles maybe so why is it why is
it that when countries where women have
more Choice the pay Gap increases it
doesn't decrease
so if you if you make a list of
countries so like let's say Saudi Arabia
women have less choice and we say in
more what is it either it's eastern
Europe Eastern Europe no no not Eastern
European it's um there's one country
where it's like but okay let's take the
US there's more free they're more free
right so when you look at countries that
are more free the pay Gap increases it
doesn't decrease and you get more women
like you get more women being nurses and
more men being doctors rather than
decreasing why do you think that is if
if it's like a generational thing
subconsciously for me I have I don't
have kids but I already feel that that's
going to be the hardest job on Earth
so I'm just like
maybe men do the rest because um
Carrie what
uh do what no my titty uh
um so I'm happy to be on this side of
stuff I'm happy I'm I'm okay I can dip
my toe in over there you know I can
carry a little one
so I can carry on one thing for you I
can help but like I think subconsciously
whether I'm conditioned or not I just
feel like giving birth and being a mum
that is for life
I'm I don't know but I feel like that's
gonna be harder that's the job as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible